I never wanted to get married when we
were younger romance seemed simple so
that place are yours I always thought
that by the time I got married I would
be different Hey I think that's too
sheeter and then suddenly
Oh Chris is going to propose to me so oh
so um I can't really hear you call me
back when you have better reception she
just needs some time to think about it
yeah I'm not saying she's a lesbian but
most girls are dying for this
Nora begged me to marry her and she was
a lesbian before all this you guys were
doing green right women get mental
tomatoes all the time maybe he's right
you're not gonna let him extort a yes
out of you are you it's not extortion an
ultimatum is an acceptable form of
negotiation extortion is illegal what
I'm gonna propose to him didn't your
boyfriend be the one doing the proposal
you tried and you said no yeah sort of
study drink know how he hit you what no
no but if I don't know how long I'm
gonna need it's okay who's gonna die
four years younger now
you
I always thought that by the time I got
married I would be different better more
like a real woman more accomplished to
clean our Boulder
who was I kidding
I mean just look at her she's probably
wearing a lady bra not a sports bra that
gives her one flat uniboob
she probably had a light gluten-free
breakfast
she's obviously traveled all over
have loads of lovers
Sonia let's Jesse my brother Chao ma
equal you see mama availa no I'm a
virgin here motto no show personal
problem we do travel guides oh you're
missing an h2 hip-stir hip-stir hip-stir
keeps the foot Rama hips user Millan
it's hip-stir hip-stir
what are they baby sees no Molly
Thank You Audrey and Roman holiday yeah
have you heard lesbian cousin hello I
need siamo mm-hmm dead dipping Walker it
didn't move yeah you didn't move around
a little bit yeah thing and not so much
robotic I got you don't pause it
yes yes grazie TV show okay and I Love
Lucy
okay Captain Hook Walking Dead The
Walking Dead yeah
stabbing I don't know anything
I'm Amanda Knox Smurfs the Smurfs girl
Marilyn Monroe Oh a Jimi Hendrix no Kurt
Cobain I don't know it's Audrey Hepburn
in Roman holiday ah
Cece
thank you no no come on no no no no I
don't I can't I don't know
come on come on oh let's go ahead like
those anyways sorry
back side two for three side for how do
you know how to do this mark and I
started a ballroom dancing club in
college to make girls one girl signed up
in about seven other dudes so we mostly
just danced with each other oh my god I
can't believe you have to start a dance
club to meet girls
mark yeah but you lately